i'm joe corcory and i lead the
healthcare and life sciences product
team at google cloud
when we first started planning for next
we intended for this talk to be about
how healthcare organizations
are transforming their businesses using
ai and ml
however since that time the world and
especially as it relates to healthcare
has seen a completely different type of
transformation as a result of covet 19.
with that in mind we decided to focus
this talk more about
how google cloud is helping
organizations respond to covid19
leveraging ai and ml google cloud's
healthcare and life sciences products
as well as some of the work that our
partners are doing
i want to start by talking through
google cloud healthcare and life
sciences team's mission
which is to create solutions to empower
provider payer and pharma organizations
to transform their business and the
delivery of healthcare
our development efforts to deliver on
that mission are primarily organized
around four main pillars
organize we want to make it easy to
ingest normalize
and join data to unlock the potential of
your data
accessible we want to support open
standards
apis interoperability and discovery to
ensure that the data can be made
accessible for use
secure we lead the industry in security
privacy and compliance from endpoint to
data center everything we do here is
core to our mission and at the heart of
our work
useful with secure accessible and
well-organized data
we aim to help organizations generate
insights and new capabilities that
advance the quadruple game of healthcare
the quadrupletum of healthcare is a
framework of goals
designed to improve the patient
experience of care
improve the health of populations reduce
the per capita cost of healthcare
and improve the work experience of
clinicians and staff
this useful pillar is especially
critical today during the covid19
pandemic
as organizations seek to understand and
take action on a wide
range of data available to them here's
our overall agenda for the session which
we've divided into three distinct parts
in the first session we will cover the
application of ai to covet forecasting
and will be joined by dr thomas i a
surgeon and health policy researcher
in the department of surgery at brigham
and women's hospital and in the
department of health policy and
management at the harvard t.h
chan school of public health he is
affiliated with the harvard global
health institute within google cloud has
partnered on the development
of the kovid 19 public forecasts in the
second session we'll dive a bit deeper
into how google cloud's healthcare
specific product offerings
are being used to address covet 19.
finally in our last session we'll
highlight work being done
by one of our partners schrodinger and
how it's being used to combat covet 19.
let's get started now i'd like to
welcome dr
tom assad to share his thoughts on our
collaboration to deliver the covet 19
public forecasts
thank you joe for that introduction as
joe said
my name is tom sai i'm a surgeon and
assistant professor in health policy and
management at the harvard school of
public health
and a faculty member of the harvard
global health institute
the goal of the harvard global health
institute is to provide actionable data
to guide
policy making to improve health in both
the united states
and the global context during coven 19
our efforts are focused around three
core areas
developing models of u.s hospital
capacity to help plan
for surge capacity to meet the demand of
covit 19 cases
supporting federal and state policy
makers in developing
testing targets and a contact tracing
strategy
and three providing scientific
communication
to combat misinformation we are public
health researchers
health policy experts and clinicians we
try to bring all those perspectives to
bear when informing policy response
to urgent health care needs such as a
kova 19 pandemic
over the last few months we have
embarked on a national conversation
in conjunction with the harvard stafford
center for ethics and multiple academic
groups
think tanks foundations and policy
groups to create convergence around a
key set of metrics
for suppression of covid19 this has
resulted in erkovit 19 risk level
dashboard and test target dashboard
globalepidemics.org our goal has been to
not just
show the underlying risk but more
importantly tie the community level
risk to a corresponding set of public
health actions
around testing and non-pharmacologic
interventions such as social distancing
and even shutdowns while the dashboard
shows us where we are
what it doesn't do is predict what will
happen in the future
because of the states and even counties
are unable to fully prepare for what is
to come
if hospitals policy makers and public
health officials
can predict with more reliability future
co-19 outbreaks then they could be
better
prepared this is where artificial
intelligence
and machine learning come into play
through aei
and machine learning we can create
forecasting models that are able to
predict cases
deaths and other important metrics over
the next 14 days
at both the u.s state and county level
and this
is where google cloud comes in
cloud ai in partnership with the harvard
global health institute has developed a
novel covid 19 forecasting model
that is able to predict cases deaths and
other important metrics such as
hospitalizations
in the 14-day period at the u.s state
and county level
these forecasts are powered by machine
learning informed epidemiological
models that continuously learn from
underlying
public data sets the forecasts are
available free to the public
to generate the covid19 public forecasts
google cloud researchers developed a
novel time series machine learning
approach
that combines artificial intelligence
with a robust epidemiological foundation
by design this new model is trained on
public data and leverages an
architecture that allows researchers to
dive into the different relationships
that the model has learned
to better interpret why it makes certain
forecasts
one of the challenges of a novel
pandemic like covet 19
is that traditional epidemiological
modeling depends on
assumptions of certain parameters such
as the transmission rate
the incubation period and the
risk of mortality what the ai machine
learning approach
enables is an opportunity to learn from
the data
in real time as we're progressing
through this pandemic
we hope that these measures not only
help the public
understand how the model works but more
importantly can enable
further innovations in infectious
disease modeling we're calling on public
health officials to prioritize data
quality and transparency
as these underlying data are what
informs and enables the ai models to
make accurate predictions of healthcare
professionals as these data are public
we hope and
end users will use these data to create
their own dashboards
to guide and inform local decision
making
there's a saying that all models are
wrong but some
models are useful the cova 19 public
forecast
model is uniquely positioned to provide
not just useful
information but more importantly
actionable insights
that can be used to help suppress the
kobe 19 pandemic
it's been our privilege at the harvard
global health institute to partner with
google cloud on this
very important effort we look forward to
continuing this ongoing collaboration
thank you thomas i really appreciate you
participating in this session
the covet 19 public forecast model
generates a 14-day forecast of the
development of covid19
in each u.s state and county it's
intended to be used as one of many
signals to help first responders in
healthcare
the public sector and other impacted
organizations to be better prepared for
what lies ahead
the data is available in bigquery where
users can interact with it directly and
without cost
as it is included in the kovid 19 public
data set program
that makes a large number of covid
related data sets freely searchable on
bigquery
the data can also be downloaded directly
as a csv for your
analysis and your own tools finally we
also created a high-level dashboard view
of the data using google data studio
which is what you're seeing here let's
take a closer look at that dashboard now
to get a better understanding of the
results
in the covid19 public forecast data
studio dashboard
you will see data projections over the
next 14 days for the united states
the forecasts are generated roughly
every day and are available for all u.s
states and counties
this dashboard shows historical data
side by side with these forecasts
the map view allows you to see which
states are expected to have the highest
increase in the number of deaths and
confirmed cases
you can also quickly navigate between
states to view the forecast for each one
let's pick arizona additional metrics
such as hospitalizations icu and
ventilator forecasts are also available
for u.s counties historical and forecast
data is available for cases
deaths and hospitalizations you can use
the drop down menu to select one or more
counties and view a time series
visualization for that county let's put
yuma
additional data at the county and state
level is available in the bigquery table
and csvs in addition to our partnership
with the harvard global health institute
we work closely with sata and hca
healthcare to make the covid19 public
forecasts
available in the national response
portal with the goal of ensuring as many
people can have access to the data as
possible
many organizations have found value from
these types of data including hca
as highlighted here by dr edmond jackson
our hope is that other organizations
will also be able to take this data
and use it to plan accordingly to
address kovid 19 needs at the hospital
level
let's change gears now to focus on
google cloud's healthcare specific
products and how they're being used to
help with the covid19 crisis
we just talked about how organizations
like hca healthcare
are benefiting from aiml for covet
forecasting
data is what powers these ml models
however the data plumbing required in
healthcare to build those models is
challenging and time-consuming
the google cloud healthcare api is
designed to make the data plumbing
easier
cheaper and faster to accelerate
healthcare data interoperability
and enable you to unlock the power of
your data to create
and or consume ai models to run
large-scale cross-modality analytics
and to build and deploy novel healthcare
applications
let's continue with the covet theme and
walk through an example of how a large
provider system was able to quickly gain
insights
into coveted missions using the
healthcare api
when covet hit it exposed a real problem
in many provider systems
the disease was moving faster than the
data that they were using to make their
decisions
some of the challenges they faced
included data latency
where their existing data analytics ran
off epic clarity exports
which can often be more than 24 hours
old
data continuity regional hospitals and
clinics each had their own siloed view
of just their own data
and finally available i.t skills a real
lack of local i.t staff
made roll out of a new technical
solution impossible
what they needed was a way to tap into
real-time events
and in particular those that are
broadcast on the hl7v2 message stream
the solution that they developed
leveraged the real-time feed by
consuming the hl7v2 message feed
directly into the healthcare api
transforming that data into fire
and then projecting that data into
bigquery for analytics
the data feeds were then combined across
regional hospitals and clinics to create
a single aggregated data set for the
entire system
they were then able to use pre-build
looker dashboards that combine national
data
with their local data as well as their
own data to gain better insights
let's dive a bit deeper into the
specifics of the solution
the google cloud healthcare api was the
key to moving from some time
to real-time analytics we're able to
plug
into the rhapsody interface engine and
land the hl7 messages directly into the
healthcare api message store
we then leveraged our data harmonization
suite to transform the hl7v2 messages
into a fire representation in real time
the healthcare api firestore can
automatically project the data through
to bigquery
and can be visualized using a looker
dashboard
traditionally standing up this kind of a
solution within the healthcare system
would take months
but we needed to act at the speed of
covet and by using the healthcare api we
were able to do this
the result was that the c-suite had
visibility into real-time data
about the number of cases resources and
utilization
and all of this was delivered from start
to finish in just three weeks
before we move on i want to take a
slightly closer look at the architecture
behind the solution
the first step in delivering this
solution was setting up the cloud
environment
using the data protection toolkit which
automates the deployment of cloud
projects and resources
following hipaa best practices
automating permissions using the
principle of lease privilege
and setting up log retention once
patients are admitted
transferred or discharged the ehr or the
electronic health record
sends out an hl7 message which our pub
sub adapter listens for captures and
delivers to the healthcare api
hl7v2 message store the hl7v2 data was
converted to fire
via transformation pipeline run in cloud
data fusion
however that wasn't the only source of
data brought into this solution
we also brought in data from operational
systems in csv format
we worked with the system to create a
whistle mapping config to harmonize the
data into fire from these different
sources
which were in different schemas
terminologies and value sets
as a result both operational and
clinical data are harmonized in real
time to the firestore
which then streams data directly into
bigquery so that the looker dashboards
reflect up-to-date information for
decision-making
as we discussed on the previous slide
there's a lot of value in the structured
data contained in the hl7 messages
and the operational data however there
is a significant amount of value locked
up in unstructured data contained in the
clinical narrative of the progress notes
extracting this value requires a
different approach
let's dive a little bit deeper into
clinical entity extraction
what you're seeing here is a small part
of a typical icu note
it's very dense there are lots of
unintuitive abbreviations
there's weird punctuation because large
sections are often generated by the ehr
and there are two languages here both
english and latin
but there is often more detail and
richness of context buried in the
clinical note
and that is important to understand and
is not available in the structured ehr
data
so what can we do about this the
healthcare natural language api
which is coming soon in beta will help
you find assess and lengthen knowledge
in your data
in particular it allows you to extract
clinically relevant entities from the
text
to understand the relationship between
those entities to understand the context
in which those entities appear in the
text
as well as to associate those with known
ontologies in addition to the
capabilities
offered by the healthcare natural
language api the need for custom
information extraction models
that have high fidelity for healthcare
and life sciences applications is
significant
automl entity extraction for healthcare
which is also coming soon
provides you with the ability to
generate high quality custom models for
healthcare applications
with no coding skills required just
upload and label the training data
train the model with a simple click and
then deploy that model at scale
a major u.s health center was seeing
patients presenting to them
with a wide variety of different
symptoms through multiple clinical entry
points
including their call centers chatbots
telemedicine visits and of course
in-person care the data that was being
collected
at these different entry points was not
connected together
and there was not an easy way to pull
all this data together to identify
common patterns
in their population in response they
decided to kick off a pilot
to automate the extraction of clinical
information from these
unstructured data sources to better make
more accurate predictions and better
triage their covid19 patients
the early results of this effort were
promising they pooled all the disparate
data sets together into a single store
and also enhanced their chat bots to ask
covid19 specific questions as well
as a result of their ability to better
extract information from multiple
sources
they've seen improvements in the
accuracy of their diagnoses
as well as a reduction in their time to
treat they're also exploring how this
can be used in the future to better
identify chronic conditions
related to covet to close
i want to highlight one of our partners
that's working
on finding new treatments for covid19
schrodinger is one of those partners
schrodinger is a drug and material
discovery company that has built a
platform that uses physics
and chemistry principles to create
computational models
that predict how different substances
will interact at the molecular level
these simulations can be run at an
enormous scale
to assess billions of molecules in
silico before selecting candidates to
take into the lab
we announced our initial partnership in
may when google cloud was providing
schrodinger with access to powerful
computing capacity
to accelerate drug discovery for its
commercial partners and its own internal
pipeline
however more recently and in response to
the covet 19 pandemic
google cloud is providing schrodinger
with 16 million hours of gpu time
through our researcher credit program
and this is to enable computational drug
discovery for covid19
which if used consecutively would equate
to 1826 years of around-the-clock
computing
to accelerate this drug discovery
process schrodinger has teamed up with
takeda
novartis gilead sciences and mushi aptec
and a philanthropic initiative to share
ideas resources
and data with the goal of developing
novel and viral therapeutics for covet
19.
we're very excited to be able to support
this initiative and we wish them the
very best of luck
we hope that you found this useful and
informative and that this will be
helpful for your organization
as you combat the covet 19 crisis we're
now in the final month of next
where we have several health care and
life science sessions that you might
find useful
you can easily find this information
linked from the google cloud healthcare
and life sciences website
or from our next home page thank you
very much